well better late than never
[Applause]
[Music]
classic doctor who reviewed time and as
usual I had my supporters over on
patreon help me decide which Doctor Who
episode I was going to be reviewing this
time and this time I gave them the
option of some of the recreations now
you know they had a number of options
including some fairly recently released
stuff and what they opted to go with was
Schad ah the lost in a way that is
unusual even by Doctor Who standards a
story of the Fourth Doctor so before I
get into this if you don't know the deal
with shot it now Doctor Who classic
error doctor who has a favorite it still
got a bit of missing material because
stuff wasn't properly archived so there
there are still a number of stories that
are either missing completely or missing
pieces or one or two parts of it here or
there that's pretty much all first and
second dr. era by third doctor we were
pretty much set so how do we end up with
a lost Fourth Doctor story well it's
because they started shooting it and
then had to stop because there was union
disputes and strikes that went on at the
BBC in the middle of the thing shooting
those strikes had nothing to do with
Doctor Who specifically but doctor who
was affected so the result was this
story that started being shot the
production got shut down in 1992 they
kind of did a preliminary recreation
thing they didn't like go back and shoot
the whole thing from scratch but they
got they had the actors record audio for
the stuff they didn't already have and
they kind of put a thing together that
was you know just so people had a sense
of what it was but so this normally
would be
creations for missing episodes you know
you get the animated stuff that's out
there like I like I did
power of the Daleks which I which I
reviewed a while back and you know that
is a case of they had the they still had
the audio but not the video so they took
the audio and the you know what notes
they had on the scripts and recreated it
as best they could hear they actually
have some of the video that was shot for
shot ax but then there's whole swath
that were never shot and they then used
either bits that were put together for
that 1992 VHS release or brought in the
surviving actors to record the lines
that they didn't already have and thus
we get shot ax now this does actually
mean that you are getting live action
video interspersed with animated
recreations and it's not a case of like
well this segment is all this and this
like it'll jump like from one to the
other to the other yeah I mean if you
know anything about the shooting
schedule of the show
you can tell very quickly oh okay they
shot all the scenes in this location and
this location and this location that
appears here here and here and
throughout the story but there's these
bits in between those that we don't have
anything up now I'm actually somewhat
familiar with the story of shot at well
I mean it's it's written by Douglas
Adams and he pilfered some of the
elements of this for some of his later
stuff the character of professor Crowe
notice particularly basically appears in
a slightly altered form in Dirk gently's
holistic detective agency so you know I
and I mean like I'm a big fan of Douglas
Adams anyway but I'm also somewhat
familiar with this because I have
already listened to and also done a
review on the audiobook version the
audio drama version of this that was
done by B I think it was done by Big
Finish but it was done with slightly
rewritten well partially you know to
have it work in audio because you know
they had to have lines explaining the
stuff that you couldn't just see but it
was also rewritten for the eighth
you're Paul McGann but the story
structurally is still the same like
little bits and pieces are different but
to the interaction and like I said the
you know things are written out in
dialogue that otherwise you know you
just would have seen but so again I did
already know this story and it's it is a
decent story it is a pretty good fourth
doctor err story it's not Douglas Adams
his best work it's not you know it's
it's not top tier but that didn't stop
them from really kind of going all out
and actually you kinda you get used to
the flicking back and forth of the live
action and be animated pretty quickly
because I would say that and and maybe
it's just by lucky coincidence that it
happened this way or maybe they actually
planned it like this I don't know like I
because I don't know how much they
messed with the original shooting script
but the very first animated scene is a
rather extended sequence with a
character where we see him you know ride
on a bike back to his apartment and then
do a number of things with no dialogue
and no audio so you just get used to the
visualisation of it in this in this
dialogue free scene and then you know
they start talking later and as far as
the animation quality goes like I mean
it's it's it's fairly rudimentary but to
compare it to other ones that I've seen
like this power of the Daleks it being
the big one and this is actually dumb
but same animation company that did
power of the Daleks this is better this
is smoother this is more frames of
animation than that one is so it's a
little less jagged it's a little less
robotic in the movements that especially
in the mouths that said you know it's
still it's still fairly cheap animation
but then again Doctor Who you know it
looked fairly cheap at the time anyway
so that in a way that's kind of oddly
fitting so plot hooey okay so the doctor
and Romana this is second incarnation of
Romana so Lalla Ward they materia they
show up at this University
and you know not entirely sure why they
got you all know they they got dropped
off there because a friend of the
doctors professor connote as I mentioned
him kind of sent them a note saying hey
I need you to come and help me sort of
something out now the professor is he's
a wonderful character I actually really
liked him a lot but it's a good thing
that he's so endearing because he's kind
of frustrating for other characters to
deal with because he is so forgetful
it's you know he just cannot hold um the
ideas straight in his head he actually
can remember pretty much anything but
like trying to recall any of it and sort
it out from all the other stuff that he
that he knows and has remembered or may
or you know it has faded to the back of
his mind he's just not great at sorting
through all that stuff but he's a really
wonderful endearing character and also
the doctor this is at a point where the
doctor and Romana are really you you can
the romantic entanglement that Tom Baker
and Lalla Ward had going on is very much
bleeding into their on-screen chemistry
and it's very lively when when they're
together and it works quite well I'll
actually say that the villain of this
one whose plan is strange and bizarre
and I'm not gonna explain because it
doesn't really get fully explained what
his goal is until towards the end um but
basically as far as what he's doing he
is shown up on earth he's tracking the
professor there's a book that the
professor at some point had that he
wants to get his hands on and he has
this sphere that like can attach to
someone and basically pull their mind
out of their body it's funny they look
and they I mean - the drill I suppose
but like that I couldn't help but think
of the the the spheres from phantasm if
you're a connoisseur of over-ambitious
slightly cheesy horror but in any case
the the villain is he actually works
better here than I
thought he was going to because it's
been a while since I've listened to the
shoutout audio but my memory was that
the villain was one of the weak elements
and it was largely because he was fairly
generic both in his characterization and
the delivery of the lines now part of
this might be the actor part of this
might be the directing that was done
maybe they even tweaked the script I
don't know but the villain plays a lot
less cackling stereotype here than than
what I remember him being in the audio
version which is nice he actually works
pretty well here is surprisingly
intimidating and pretty calm throughout
I have a feeling they were probably they
probably had the ability to tweak this
character the most because he honestly
has very little of his stuff shot he is
he is animated for the vast majority of
his screen time so I wouldn't be
surprised if there was some tinkering
with that character versus maybe what
would happened if it had all been shot
you know back when it was originally
being worked on there's also some really
fun like little nods like it opens up
you know with the BBC know the logo and
if you had been watching BBC in the air
at the time they had just these little
things like and now we bring you the
latest adventure of Doctor Who and you
know whatever it but but it opens with
something like that but it says a little
bit later than originally planned to be
broadcast and then they also have a
little thing at the very end which is
also like really nice and cool and sweet
and I enjoy it a lot and I'm not going
to spoil so there's some nice little
nods to the fact that getting anything
close to a proper rendition of this has
taken for ever but it's it's it's quite
nice like I said it's I'm definitely
glad that it exists but you know to
compare it to the other stuff that
Douglas Adams's had has had his hands
most directly on from from Doctor Who I
don't think it I think it easily runs
third I think pirate planet is notably
better and I think it doesn't even hold
a candle to city of death but it's still
pretty good
it's got less of the Douglas Adams
wit to it there's some of it there but
it's not as humor heavy either in
premise or in lines but it does have the
sort of sci-fi concepts that Adams
tended to to deal in and that is nice to
see on display because that his his
conceptual stuff was always a good fit
for Doctor Who so overall like I did
enjoy this and and everybody give us a
good performance it's surprising I was
actually surprised how seamless the
vocal performances were in terms of the
animated recreations vocally matching
the older stuff because I've noted
before when I have done like say audio
dramas with Tom Baker as the fourth
doctor I can hear the age in his voice I
actually hear it a lot less here than I
do in the Big Finish so I don't know
again if they had like done like some
After Effects to like really try and
make it match up and the the voice for
k9 isn't John Leeson though it's
somebody else and I don't know why well
I did look it up I confirmed it was
somebody else but I couldn't find like a
quick and easy answer as to why somebody
other than then John Leeson was voicing
k9 and like I research you know beyond
the most basic I'm not cut out for it
so that bat did bug me a little but it's
just because I'm like that doesn't sound
quite right but that's that's nitpicking
at this point and I don't really want to
nitpick this thing it is
well-constructed it's well put together
it's the doctor and Romana they've got
fantastic chemistry the villain has an
interesting idea the guest characters
are pretty good there's also like a
human character a guy named I think it
was Chris and sort of a colleague that
he that he has a bit of a crush on there
they're kind of superficial supporting
characters but they're also sweet and
they don't bug me which honestly is
enough sometimes with some of these
supporting characters and I yeah I was I
was happy to have got
I'm seeing this cuz like because I'd
already heard the audio I was like do I
even need to see it well no I did
because even though narrative lis it's
pretty much the same thing it does have
enough of a different feel just by
having a different doctor in it and it's
funny because I like I've been asked
before you know what's a story where you
put a different doctor in it and how do
you think it would change in like that's
not like a mental exercise that I'm cut
out for like I can't quite fit those
pieces together in my head this kind of
gave me my first taste of that though of
how a different doctor and the same
adventure alters the feel and the vibe
of the thing and it's it's interesting
so not only would I recommend this I
would actually recommend also seeking
out the the audio drama version with
Paul McGann and just contrasting and
seeing you know the different ways that
the same story can be told I think
especially if you have an interest in in
narrative and writing it's a wonderful
contrast just to see how much of a
difference like little changes make but
yeah we'll wrap it up there shut up have
you seen it or heard it or read it
because it was a novelization for a
while it might have even gotten a
reprint and when this came out I don't
know but however you've experienced it
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
to do buttons links patreon I mentioned
it already but you know really helps a
whole bunch of other stuff besides and
give it a look all sorts of things down
there um but also you know you don't
have to it's okay because at the end of
the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]